on va démarrer par vous raquel garrido
voulait poser une question à yann moix
bonsoir fort yann moix moi j'ai envie de
croire votre récit familial et en plus
je me sens absolument pas la légitimité
ou l'autorité de contester des faits
ainsi énoncé même de façon littéraire en
plus on est avocat de profession jeu
j'ai une certaine technique pour établir
la vérité qui fait que je me sentirais
pas de de vous opposer de vous traiter
de menteur
donc j'ai envie de vous croire mais en
revanche j'ai aussi envie de croire
votre frère pour les mêmes raisons et
aussi parce que fondamentalement je
pense que c'est parfaitement possible et
crédible lorsqu'on est soi-même victimes
de violences bah justement du coup de
battre les autres et donc au fond la
question que j'aimerais vous poser c'est
si vous êtes prêts à reconnaître quand
même que en plus d'avoir été vous même
victime
vous avez pu faire de votre frère votre
mythe victime également à quel bon soir
on se connaît un petit peu excellent de
questions et j'ai dit répondre de la
manière la plus naturelle
on accuse un enfant de frapper un autre
enfant on accuse un enfant de 6 ans de
frapper un enfant de deux ans on accuse
un enfant de 9 ans de frapper un enfant
en un enfant de 5 ans donc quand on
m'accuse de maltraitance c'est pas
l'homme de 51 ans qui l'a on m'accuse
l'enfant on accuse de l'enfant de 1918
d'avoir fait ça il se trouve que je ne
les ai pas fait mais je considère qu'il
ya dans cette affaire deux martyrs il y
a quelqu'un qui était martyrisé de
manière active
tout mon oeuvre de 1996 à aujourd'hui
tout mon oeuvre
tous mes livres ne parle que de ça j'ai
été martyrisé activement et je considère
qu'il ya une autre victime dans cette
affaire c'est pourquoi je n'ai aucune
haine envers mon frère une autre victime
est une victime passive
il était victime d'un spectacle atroce
du spectacle de son frère martyrisée
dans un tweet qu'il a publié sur
facebook je crois donc c'est pas un
tweet sur facebook un post facebook on à
janvier 2019
on a alors alexandre mon frère
yann moix qui est un petit prince qu'on
a assassiné j'étais là j'ai vu j'ai
entendu j'ai subi j'ai pleuré j'ai
frissonné j'ai eu peur je me suis tu
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de hurler jan
nous savons tous les deux étaient vos
relations à cette époque écoutez c'est
très simple donc je termine pour akalé
il y a eu de violence une violence
active violences massives infligées à un
enfant le spectacle de son frère martin
et c'est horrible d'autant plus que cet
enfant là lui avaient le pouvoir de vie
et de mort sur moi sur un petit
gémissement sur des pleurs sur un
reportage
j'étais massacre est massacrée se voient
dans des proportions
j'ai même enlever des choses dans le
livre pour rester crédible et si vous
voulez dans rompre un livre où je
parlais de la rupture sentimentale et
j'expliquais la manière dont mes parents
me faisait manger des excréments la
manière dont je recevais des coups de
fils électriques et mon frère ce que
vous pourriez parler sérieusement pour
effaré par ce qu'il a lu parce que c'est
la réveiller des souvenirs a considéré
qu'il fallait témoigner en ma faveur au
mois de janvier
effectivement au mois de septembre il a
donné une version totalement
contradictoire pourquoi c'est une
question à laquelle j'ai une réponse
personnelle ça on peut en débattre
mon frère a toujours vie vécue depuis sa
plus tendre enfance dans une obsession
alors il ya plusieurs obsession chez lui
mais une obsession le prix goncourt
depuis dix livres cyril ou qu'un livre
je parle des maltraitances n'ai jamais
eu de problème jamais mon frère n'est
jamais intervenu mes parents se sont
jamais plaints d'ailleurs personne ne
m'a fait de procès là aujourd'hui je ne
suis attaqué par rien ça aurait été de
la diffamation
mes parents ont dû saisir le livre
m'attaquer rien dans le livre de mon
frère qui s'appelle second rôle que j'ai
ici il ya plus de quinze occurrence avec
le mot boncourt de dans l'hypothèse qui
est la mienne elle peut être discuté
parce que je n'ai pas la science infuse
même sur mon frère c'est que il y a
chez lui un refus de me voir après
tribus et le prix goncourt
quand j'ai eu le prix renaudot il se dit
c'est pas grave c'est un second prix est
là quand on lit son livre on s'aperçoit
qu'il ne parle que de ça pour avoir la
paix il voulait ma sécurité que je
devienne salariés plutôt qu artiste mes
parents un baise en ville contre un
goncourt
à l'époque sa petite amie dorine m'avait
largué pour une espèce d'abruti en me
largue ans elle voulait me dire toi tu
n'auras jamais prix goncourt etc
les pleurs j'ai rêvé d'être aussi bon
que la couverture du prix goncourt et je
crois cyril pour répondre clairement
votre question qu'il a cru que j'allais
vers le bon cours je suis un bruit qui
circule est hélas il s'est senti
immédiat il s'est dit ah non moi vous
savez cyril je n'ai pas réussi ma vie
quand on est frappé par ses parents on
peut réussir dans la vie on ne peut pas
réussir sa vie
vous êtes toujours malheureux toujours
quand vous avez été martyrisé quasiment
chaque jour de l'âge de 2 ans à l'âge de
16 ans la seule échappatoire qui vous
restent cd réussir dans la vie
parce que réussir sa vie c'est plus
possible il ya un a brisé mais
totalement quand vous avez des parents
pathogènes des parents foule hystérique
violent brutaux et même barbare il ya
deux solutions
sans aller et les fuir pour se
reconstruire
ou bien rester et celui qui reste là en
l'occurrence c'est mon frère celui qui
reste se détruit là le voisinage avec
des barbares n'est pas bon pour le
psychisme humain et donc il n'a pas su
s'en aller il n'a pas su vivre sa vie il
continue à vivre la vie de mes parents
avec mes parents auprès des pans qu'ils
entretiennent depuis l'âge de 18 ans et
finalement il a regardé ma vie se
déployer en spectateur en se disant
pourquoi pas moi